Well, good morning everybody, or good afternoon,
depending on what time zone you're in.
Welcome to the BD2K guide to the fundamentals
of data science.
I'm Michelle Dunn, I'm in the office of the
associate director for data science.
Please go to the next slide.
I just wanted to say a few things about where
we are in this series.
We started with a wonderful talk by Mark Musen
in early September that gave us an overview
of really all of data science, and then immediately
jumped into section one, which was about data
management.
So data management, we heard about indexing
and binding data within the data management
section.
But mainly about how to make data that is
usable.
So how to make data that's well curated, following
standards for metadata, and including prominent
information.
Now we're into section two.
Section two is titled Data Representation,
but really it's about getting data into usable
format.
This will take us through the end of the calendar
year.
And then starting next year in 2017, we'll
start up again with a section on computing
followed by a section on analysis, and then
other topics like ethics.
Can you go to the next slide?
So I'm sorry, I have a mistake here.
I should be highlighting the section two data
representation, which is where we're at, not
computing.
But data representation includes topics such
as databases and data warehouses, wrangling,
normalization of pre-processing.
Those topics we have two guest speakers speak
on that for two weeks.
And then natural language processing and exploratory
data analysis.
But today we are incredibly lucky-- can you
go to the next slide?
We're incredibly lucky to have with us Dr.
Anita Bandrowski, who is currently at UCSD
and has a background in both neurophysiology
and bioinformatics.
She trained in neurophysiology at UC Riverside
and at Stanford.
She is the founder and CEO of SciCrunch, in
addition to being a part of the NIF, the Neuroscience
Information Framework.
And she works at the Center of Research and
Biological System at UCSD on these two things,
NIF and SciCrunch.
And NIF and SciCrunch work together in order
to aggregate vast amounts of data.
Though she's really an expert in this area
of knowing what to do with the data.
So I really look forward to her talk, and
I know we all really appreciate that you are
taking the time, Dr. Bandrowski, to come talk
with us today.
And so with that, I think please take away.
The floor is all yours.
Thank you so much.
And what I will do in just a second to switch
over to my slide deck, and I will then mute
my speakers.
So if you need to get a hold of me, please
do so in the message box.
So I think now we will have better,
clearer voice.
So in this guide to the fundamentals of data
science, as Michele had pointed out very poignantly,
this is an overview of data representation.
And I have worked on the Neuroscience Information
Framework for about 10 years.
And the goal of that particular project at
the University of California San Diego is
to make as much data available and useful
to people, mostly to neuroscientists.
And so many of the examples that I will use
will actually be from that particular project.
But I do also recognize that there are some
core fundamental things that happen.
So in terms of the overview of data representation.
The lecture series will cover things like
types of data, databases, and data warehouses.
I think it's wonderful we have a wonderful
list of speakers, including a Dr Chaitan Baru,
who also used to be up the road from us at
the supercomputing center.
Doctors Picone, and I am going to butcher
Doctor Harabagiu's name, and some of the others.
But I wanted to point out when these lectures
are and what are the sorts of things they're
covering.
Today I will cover in a small amount of detail
the basics of databases, the basics of data
wrangling, and then you should be able to
know a whole lot more from Doctor Baru and
others.
So one of the very basic questions is, what
is data?
And I just wanted to make sure that all of
the vocabulary terms have definitions, as
this is supposed to be kind of a primer lecture.
So data is the facts and statistics collected
together for reference or analysis.
We'll also refer to metadata, which is data
about data.
And actually, when you think about it, one
person's metadata is another person's data,
so then you could have metadata of metadata.
And can go on from there.
But another term that I think you should know
is what is a schema?
And it's basically the structure of the data.
What does it look like?
And this has a very set of specific meanings
when you start to talk about databases.
What do we look across biology?
Data is incredibly diverse.
And again, this is one of the examples from
neuroscience, but you can substitute the brain
into a kidney, and to a liver, and to whatever
else you might want to look at, and essentially
the problem is extraordinarily similar.
Biologists think about interactions of very,
very tiny things.
They look at NMR, they look at other spectroscopies.
They look at data types of that sort on Brownian
motion, and they look all the way to the social
interactions of animal herds.
In fact there is a fun study published by
a group of ecologists-- also biologists--
trying to figure out how to use Google Maps
to determine whether cows point mostly north-south
or east-west when they were going to use themselves
in herds.
And they look at everything in between.
So they were looking at intracellular currents,
they're looking at MRI images.
They were looking at latency to button presses,
and all kinds of other things.
So the data that comes from all of these different
techniques can be incredibly variable.
So really, biological data is characterized
by diversity.
Because it can be text, there can be time
series, it can be categorical, there can be
images, there can be video, there can be locations--
geolocations and locations within the body.
And all of these things actually are data,
and they're data for different biologists.
But when we look at data type, it's a little
bit different than that.
So when I was trying to prepare for this lecture,
there was this piece of data on my desktop,
and so here it is.
And there is application, specificity, clone,
quantity, and quantity type.
And when a biologist looks at this particular
piece of data-- this just happened to be on
my desk last week-- they might start thinking
about what this data actually means.
So one of the things that I've learned by
being part of the Neuroscience Information
Framework is that biologists think about data
very differently from computer scientists.
And biologists tend to imbue the data with
meaning.
So what does it mean to me?
Well, application, WB.
OK, that's western blot.
So I need an antibody that works for western
blot.
Clearly this is a piece of data about antibodies.
And these are some of the things here in the
pink boxes that a biologist might think about
when they see this piece of data.
But if you're a computer scientist, or a data
scientist, you might start thinking about
this same piece of data, the same exact spreadsheet,
slightly differently.
They might need to think about what the structure
of this data is.
That there is an IF comma WB.
This is a comma delimited list.
They might think about the specificity not
as something that I might or might not use,
but they're actually thinking about, well,
what is the external lookup that will be required
in order to explain this specificity better?
This is actually a lookup to NCBI gene.
Clone number they're a little bit confused
about, because this is free text.
But quantities and quantity types, they're
thinking about the types of operations that
they might do on data that is numerical.
So data type is a particular kind of data
item defined by the values it can take-- whether
it's text or number-- the programming language
that's used, or the operations that can be
performed on it.
So again, we can do things to numbers that
we cannot do to a list.
And so if we look across disciplines, it's
not the same thing.
So when computer scientists look at data,
they imbue it with structure.
And data types, I've listed some here, there
are many more.
These come from SQL.
Data types are obviously text controlled vocabularies,
which you heard about from Doctor Musin and
actually Doctor [INAUDIBLE] and others.
There are gene names, which these are the
sorts of things there are.
They're free text, there are all kinds of
different types of numbers, and there are,
of course, dates and other things.
But why do we care about data types?
Turns out the only time you really deeply
care about data types is when
you want to put data into a database.
And a database is essentially a structured
set of data that's held in a computer, especially
one that's accessible in various ways.
So really to understand what a database is
I wanted to go back and just ask, what are
some of the things that a database can do?
It's essentially a container for different
types of data.
It's a container for data files.
You can think of it as a file system on your
computer.
So our little example here for this spreadsheet
of antibodies could be part of the database
as long as it's accessible on a computer.
So what are the kinds of operations that I
could do if this was part of a database?
Well, I could do things like count the number
of rows that have western blot, that are like
western blot.
Which antibodies work for western blot?
You can get that.
And the answer would be all four of these.
You can select rows where specificity actually
is one of these zinc figure proteins, or the
other one.
And then it would bring you back the data
about that particular row or that particular
data item, depending on what you asked.
You could find all rows where quantity is
larger than or smaller than a particular value.
So essentially the database is a container
that's very useful in many ways in order to
ask questions about a particular dataset.
But you can do this as a biologist, and I
bring this piece in to this overview lecture
because most biologists use Excel.
And Excel is an incredibly powerful tool.
And most people know all kinds of things about
Excel.
It is one of these programs that's incredibly
powerful, incredibly ubiquitous.
But also every tool has its limitations.
So I wanted to make sure that whoever doesn't
know about these limitations knows about them
after this lecture.
So one of the limitations of Excel is size.
So there is a certain number of data points,
a certain number of data rows and data columns
that Excel will take.
And it is important to understand if we have
data of a certain size, a certain number of
rows, that simply would be too large for Excel
to take.
And so it's one of the limitations that everyone
needs to be concerned about and aware of of
Excel.
The most recent-- and actually for the last
probably five, 10 years-- versions of Excel
have been getting more and more aggressive
in terms of autocorrecting.
So autocorrecting here in this particular
article-- this is now quite old, but it hasn't
changed so we should continue to be aware
of it-- it is that gene names actually become
dates.
So this is something that my Excel did, and
I have the latest version of Excel running
on a Mac.
And so what this is doing is, I put in the
APR 4 gene.
As soon as I hit enter, it became the 4th
of April.
And the way that that's coded in Excel is
the number 42 464.
64.
So if I put in 1,000 genes into my particular
spreadsheet, and some of them were APR 4 genes,
then I would have a very large mistake in
my spreadsheet.
And this has certainly been called out in
this paper and many others.
So it's something that one must be aware of.
The other problem with this is that when you
change from an Excel sheet that's actually
in a Mac to one that's in a PC, and so you're
passing a file over to your graduate student,
your PI, your fellow at whatever institute,
and they happen to have a different operating
system and a different version of Excel.
What ends up happening is that mistakes like
this, which now become coded-- so April 4th
becomes coded as this particular number--
that number is only April 4th for a PC, or
it's only April 4th for Mac.
It will not be the same number if you switch
operating systems.
So in a sense it is a really bad idea to handle
a lot of data, especially large data where
there are genes involved on Excel it is an
extremely bad idea because there are these
known differences between the dates the date
columns and how Excel actually handles them.
This is another type of mistake that is very
common.
So here I've taken the ZNF 622 gene, and instead
of copying and pasting that gene I just drag
down the little icon.
And the newer versions of Excel, again, will
not only iterate by one number when you only
have a number, but they will actually iterate
to add one number to almost any column that
has a number in it.
So this is another thing that one must be
aware of, and I see a lot of data, and this
is the kind of mistake that I see unfortunately
quite often.
So how can I really understand a database?
So again, in order to get biologists to understand
what computer scientists are thinking, I want
to bring in some of the things that computer
scientists and data scientists would be actually
concerned with when they see our file.
So computer scientists very, very, very, very
concerned with efficiency of data retrieval,
with the size of the total file, with the
data types, which we just discussed, and with
the types of operations that need to be done
on that data.
So this particular Excel file, actually I
have saved it on my desktop in different formats.
And this is something that we've all done,
and I'm sure that all biologists basically
largely ignore this unless there's some reason
to pay attention to it.
So this particular file is a 46 kilobyte Excel
file save as latest version of Excel.
If I save the same information as a PDF it
actually becomes a 12 kilobyte file, so you
can see that there's a very large difference.
But as CSV or text it actually becomes much,
much smaller.
So that really reflects something that, again,
for most biologists, we don't care.
My computer is large enough to handle any
of these kind of files.
But the larger the file size you have, actually
the more you have to care about this sort
of question, these sort of ideas.
So again, understanding a database is really
taking this particular example of this file.
What we can see is that computer scientists,
because they are very concerned with the process
of efficiency of data storage, efficiency
of data retrieval, and the size of data, they
have driven these spreadsheets down from 153
bytes to even smaller and smaller sizes so
that you can actually store much more data
in the same space.
And one of the ways that this happens is through
a process called normalization of data.
So here I've normalized this particular table,
the one in yellow, into the two tables in
green.
And the column I've normalized is the specificity
column.
So here you will notice that there's a zinc
finger protein here, there's a different one
here, and there are two rows for for zip kinase.
And now the way that we can make this spreadsheet
even smaller is actually to code the fact
that zinc finger protein 622 is actually now
corresponding to the number one, the other
zinc finger is two, and these two zip kinases
are both 3.
And now there is something called a key value
pair.
So the number one corresponds to this, number
two this, number three, this.
And what that does over millions of rows is
it further decreases the size of the data,
which is great.
It speeds up retrieval of data, which is great.
But the more rows and the more columns that
actually look like this, the more data that
looks like this, the less readable it is by
a human.
This spreadsheet, I would argue, is relatively
well readable by a human.
But once you start changing out a lot of the
actual labels with numbers, what starts to
happen is that you can no longer read it.
You have to do a lookup for each thing, and
those kind of operations to make the spreadsheet
back into something that's human readable
really starts to take a data wrangler.
And I'll talk a little bit more about this.
So what I'm talking about here are a lot of
relational databases.
Now relational databases, the reason that
I'm talking about them is because they handle
very large files very, very well.
So you don't have to stick to just a million
rows of data.
These are some of the oldest and the most
common databases throughout the internet.
They run banks, they run stores, they run
all kinds of transactions, they run many,
many websites.
Everywhere you have a box you probably are
filling out a form that goes into a database.
So we have a lot of interaction with databases,
even if we don't necessarily know that we
do.
They do allow multiple users, including multiple
machines, to actually add data simultaneously
to the same data store.
They allow data to be extracted at the same
time as it's put in.
There are lots and lots of things that people
can do if with these.
There's a tremendous amount of diversity in
terms of what can they be programmed to actually
do, and there is, of course, a programming
interface which makes everything very flexible.
But as every tool, it is very, very understandable
that there are some limitations.
So one of the first limitations for biologists
specifically is that these kinds of databases
are actually more difficult to set up than
an Excel file, or a Google Doc.
It is more difficult to do some of the simple
operations like copy this data into that particular
space.
There is no undo button, there is no autocorrect.
Which is either a limitation or a high benefit,
depending on where you sit.
And they are very dependent on data structures.
So you have to predefine what you want to
actually have in the database before you can
actually fill in the data.
in the database before you can actually fill
in the data.
So this is something that is a limitation
that many computer scientists have actually
considered as a very significant limitation.
And they have created a whole bunch of new
types of databases, which essentially are
much newer, less common.
And most of these database types have been
created to solve one or more of the shortcomings
of the standard traditional relational databases.
So Neo4J, for example, does a lot of very
efficient computation on graph structures,
and I think that will be covered by Doctor
Baru and others.
MongoDB does really wonderful things with
text storage and retrieval being very, very
much more efficient than the conventional
SQL databases.
But new tools, as all new tools, have smaller
numbers of people that can support them, and
not all the kinks are usually worked out from
a lot of these newer databases.
So when you're choosing how to store data
it's important to consider some of these things.
Not just always go for the newest best thing,
because there may be some lacks of support.
So really I wanted to ask the question, what
makes a database useful to biologists?
And this is something I've run into, and my
colleagues have run into.
Because I am trained as a biologist, I see
data from this perspective quite a bit.
So what computer scientists think that biologists
want to do with databases is actually quite
different than what biologists actually want
to do with databases.
And so one of the things that computer scientists
often think is that biologists are just dying
to create hypotheses based on-- and here I
have pointed out, this is a gratuitous graphic.
I figured it wouldn't be a big data talk without
one of these lovely hairballs.
This is lovingly referred to as a data hairball.
Now, computer scientists really think that
biologists would love to create hypotheses
based on data.
Now, I haven't run into many biologists that
actually would like to do this.
Mostly they have a hypothesis in their head
already that's based on reading literature
and understanding biology.
But it would be really nice if we could do
that in the future.
Also, comparing their data to other people's
data, biologists have a really hard time doing
that.
And actually it's one of the things that biologists
are really reluctant to be able to do.
And exploring data space is one of those things
where it's nice, but it often doesn't go right
into the middle of the biologist's pipeline
in terms of what they're doing in the lab
actively.
What biologists actually use databases for
is they look up papers.
Now, I haven't been able to find exact numbers
in terms of the internet traffic to biological
databases, but I do know from various sources
that the vast majority-and this is a very,
very high majority-- of all web traffic to
any database in biomedicine actually goes
just to one.
That one is PubMed.
That is a database, and it is where everyone
goes.
Biologists do share data, and they store data
in databases, but they often don't look for
data there.
Bio informaticians do, and so that's a whole
different story.
But biologists tend to just take their data
and put it somewhere.
And they need to make sure that that's relatively
easy.
Biologists also are starting to use databases
as a lookup.
So for example, NCBI gene, I need to store
my data, I need to figure out what other gene
is related to my gene.
Is my snip in this place or in that place?
What are the places, and who else has published
on that particular snip?
So there's a lookup function.
But for the lookup function, you need to understand
the database has to be relatively complete.
So for biologists to actually use a particular
database as a lookup function, it has to have
that completeness.
Unless it's useful as a storage device, in
which case there's no question there, and
completeness is not necessary.
So how many databases are there currently
for biologists?
I've tried to look at some of these numbers,
and I try to do some lookups in both WorldCat,
so this is the library catalog of resources,
including a whole section of internet resources.
And what they have is about 5,200 databases,
but this covers all fields.
So it's geology and everything else.
In the Neuroscience Information Framework,
we have cataloged 2,600 of them essentially.
So these are all biologically relevant databases,
or largely biologically relevant databases.
So that's the kind of thing that we're looking
at.
And NCBI, which is the National Library of
Medicine, there are 150 databases that are
housed actually inside of NCBI.
Of course, everyone knows PubMed.
Most people know PubMed Central, but there
is actually 150 others, including some that
you probably know, and many that you've never
heard of.
But I would encourage all people to explore
where some of these other databases are At
EBI, 53 databases are actually housed, including
Europe PubMed Central.
So a way to get articles for Europeans.
ArrayExpress, which is very similar to Geo,
ChEMBL, and others.
But the biologists might ask, with all of
these different databases-- and here I've
actually pulled out some of the keywords from
the neuroscience information framework system
for all databases, and the organisms that
have been tacked to those particular database
entries.
So essentially, if you're a biologist and
you're looking for a human genetics database,
you will have hundreds to choose from.
So if you have the choice of trying to find
your data in hundreds of databases, or thousands
of databases, you might ask some questions
as a biologist.
How many of these are still alive?
How many of these are still being added to?
Which ones are being cited, which ones are
being used?
Which ones house actually the same data?
So we know that a ArrayExpress and Geo actually
house many of the same data sets.
Which ones are the gold standard?
Where do I put my data so that it gets saved
and kept?
And this particular question is not just being
asked by biologists, but it's also being asked
by the journals.
Because the journals need to ask the question,
OK, I have an author who has a particular
type of data.
Where do I send that author to deposit that
data?
We know that depositing the data is important.
We want to go along with the standards that
are being put forward by the granting agencies,
but where do I go?
There are 2,600 databases that might be relevant
to them.
Which ones are the ones I should actually
point them to?
Computer scientists actually look at this
landscape and think other thoughts.
They think, well, which ones are relational,
which ones are MongoDB based?
Which ones have this or that kind of schema?
How can I get data out of this or that one?
They're looking also at standards, and which
ones are structured in a particular way.
And again, Susanne [INAUDIBLE] I would encourage
you, if you hadn't seen the last lecture to
see the last lecture in this series.
But she did a very nice job discussing some
of this in terms of the standards of databases
that are being used through bio sharing.
So if I'm a biologist, there are 30 databases
relevant to me.
How do I navigate, inquiry this number?
Because we have to remember, databases are
not completely standard.
In fact, they're very likely to not be very
standard.
Each one has its own interface.
Each one has its own organizational system.
Each database has its own caveats.
Each database may reference a completely different
standard in terms of how it stores its data.
So how do I navigate this mess, essentially?
And this is where we actually have to learn
about the data warehouse.
And the data warehouse is essentially a whole
bunch of databases put into one system so
that somebody can run a query across those
30 databases.
But of course, in a data warehouse, what we
can actually start to do is we can ask questions
of all these multiple databases.
We can ask a question such as, which Parkinson's
disease causing snip, this [INAUDIBLE] house,
that may have a homologous mutation in a worm?
This is something that can be asked of three,
or four, or five databases together, but not
of any one.
Because one database may not have all of the
right links, all of the right connections,
to ask that sort of question.
So a data warehouse starts to broaden the
scope of a particular database and starts
to connect the different databases based on
different rules in terms of how a particular
set of data can interact with another set
of data.
How can a particular database talk to another
database, and what are the sorts of things.
So here I'm showing you an example of one
data warehouse system.
This data warehouse system actually, the thing
I have highlighted here is the RID strain
data for worms.
This is a worm base table, which talks about
the
genotype of these particular c elegans.
And within this particular database, which
is a data warehouse, there's a lot of other
data, including neuron DB.
There's data from worm mine.
There is data from homology, and there is
data from all of these other databases.
But then as soon as you start to hold this
amount of data and this kind of data, the
thing that happens is you're very, very concerned
about when that data actually came in, because
it might be old.
What were the data transformations?
So there is something on worm base.
Now, we made some assumptions in order to
create these particular tables.
Those assumptions need to be absolutely explicit.
Those are data transformations that happen
between what worm base says and what we say
worm base says.
So there are these assumptions that are made.
There is a provenance in terms of when the
data entered our system when the data was
released from the worm base site is another
set of provenance, right?
So there are a lot of things to know when
these are metadata about the particular database
table that you're looking at.
What am I looking at?
Very important to know.
So these are all very meaningful things that
need to be answered.
So when you do this though, let's say we want
to put together 30 databases.
Each database basis makes a lot of different
assumptions about the data.
If I want to do this myself in my lab, will
my programmer computer science colleagues
actually deal with the kinds of complexity
that a lot of these biological databases house
and contain?
Will I be able to interact with them well
enough to get them to understand what it is
that the data actually is supposed to mean
so that the structure can reflect that properly?
So data wrangling is a term that's been thrown
around quite a bit.
But we're starting to have an understanding
of what a data wrangler is.
But in terms of what is it, it's a process
of extracting data from both tools, databases,
and basically putting it into your tool or
database or warehouse.
So it's a data stewardship function.
But if we want to look at the job description,
what must this person really know?
If you have a data wrangler, what must they
know?
Well, this is a fun job description.
But this person must have a deep, deep knowledge
of the meaning of the data.
So a Ph.D. In biological science really helps.
Because that person would be expected to understand
the caveats of that data.
Deep knowledge of clinical and genetic databases.
Each of these databases, again, has its own
caveats.
They all take a certain kind of data, they
don't take other data.
They can be queried in ways that others cannot
be queried.
Data structures are also very important to
understand for this person.
So computer languages, statistics, Excel and
Arc all really, really important, as well
as a knowledge of ontologies, the deeper the
better.
So the kind of person that needs to do this
wrangling is the person that sits between
computer science and biology.
That person must have a deep understanding
of all of the ways that biology has of dealing
with the data, and all of
the little things that can go wrong with that
particular data.
And of course, the computer science, which
is the structure.
How do you now pull this so that it's properly
structured into a warehouse?
So the kind of things that biologists do,
which end up having to deal with a whole lot
of wrangling of data-- and there's a lot of
data wranglers over at Craig Venter's company,
Human Longevity, which just produced this
very nice paper in proceedings of National
Academy, where they've just released the deep
sequencing of 10,000 human genomes.
You can imagine, this is 10,000 data points
for each particular genome, and each genome
will have many, many, many, many, many, many,
many millions of data points in and of itself.
So making sure that getting that right, putting
everything into one single warehouse, is actually
the work of a large number of data wranglers.
So let's take this down into a more understandable
level.
So if we think of data wrangling as doing
laundry, there are these terms called manual
curation.
So the way that we can think about data wrangling,
if we're thinking laundry terms, is manual
curation is sorting everything into appropriate
piles.
There's something called semantic mapping.
And semantic mapping is assigning the proper
word to each of the piles.
So here we have shirts in one pile and socks
in another pile.
So these are two terms.
Now these piles are semantically mapped.
There's automatic indexing, and I think you
heard a lot about that previously.
Now we know that there are 10 shirts and five
socks.
Wonderful.
And there's a resource identifier.
So the research identifier is something I
also want to spend a little bit of time on
because that's how we can trace back to what
we actually have in the data warehouse.
So if we look at semantic mapping first, semantic
mapping is essentially adding a term to a
particular data item.
And there are different ways to do that.
Again, Mark Musin and Suzanne [INAUDIBLE]
had actually done a lot of the work in terms
of explaining how some of these terminologies
get put onto different data systems, so I'm
not going to talk about it a whole lot here.
But an ontology is essentially a very, very
structured glossary or thesaurus.
It's essentially a way of saying this is the
thing that I'm talking about.
And the semantic clarity of an ontology is
very, very high compared to even a taxonomy.
A taxonomy is something that we understand.
We know that mammals are related to rats.
And we know exactly how they're related because
there are different steps in between those
two terms.
But an ontology is even better than that.
So for example, here when we look at an intelligent
of socks, we know that a sock is a type of
clothing and clothing to it typically has
part thread.
So these are all terms that can be related
to one another.
Now if you say I am going to label my particular
set of data with the word sock, now if I do
it with just a controlled vocabulary, that's
great because then you can find all socks.
But if your database has thousands of different
items or millions of different items, maybe
you want to look for all things that are clothing.
And if you want to look for all things that
are clothing, if you mark your data with a
controlled vocabulary, that controlled vocabulary
doesn't know that sock and shirt is related.
That controlled vocabulary doesn't know that
sock and shirt is a type of clothing.
But if you mark with an ontology, those relationships
are inside of the system of tagging.
Which means that what you can actually do
is you can ask a database or a database system
for all clothing.
And I'll show you some of that in a little
bit.
Well, not with clothing, more of the genes.
But OK.
So when we also look and think about the stable
unique identifiers, this is a really big deal.
There's actually a big conference coming up
in Iceland next week.
But here is a set of numbers that you may
or may not recognize.
There is a telephone number.
And in my telephone I see that number, and
it has a little translation.
I used to be able to remember these numbers,
but I don't anymore because now my phone says,
oh, it's your mom calling.
Great.
So that number has been translated by my phone
to a label, Mom, or Jane Doe, or whoever.
We don't know this number, but we should because
we go to it every day.
This is the NCBI server at the National Library
of Medicine, which houses PubMed.
So we're on this particular number a whole
lot.
But when we type in Google, when we Google
the word PubMed, this is actually the number
that we're hitting.
So each database server has a number, it's
an IP number.
And we no longer understand that that number
exists, but believe me, it does.
And Phil Borne here, in this particular perspective,
has told us that essentially each of the items
needs this kind of number.
Data software narratives, all sorts of things,
must be uniquely identified.
They must be sharable.
Because this is how computers talk to one
another.
So identifiers-- all the paper identifiers
of us, identifiers of items within the paper--
really can tell you a whole lot that pretext
or beautiful prose may not be able to tell
you if you're a computer.
So we have some nice examples here.
The re15869 is a snip inside of the BRCA2
gene.
The NCBI tax on 9606 corresponds to human.
So if these two identifiers are actually inside
of a particular paper, a machine can tell
you that this paper reference is a cancer
causing snip in humans.
Now if you're reading one paper, not a big
deal.
You can probably read that.
But it turns out that about a million papers
are published every year in PubMed.
More than a million now, actually.
Which ones do you really want to read?
Is there some way that we can know better
about which ones we want to read?
Maybe there are some colleagues that you didn't
know you had from another part of the world.
We actually might need to get some assistance
from Siri-like robots.
Siri helps me navigate my way through
different parts of different cities, tells
me which restaurants are reasonable or within
a particular price range.
Why can't Siri help me find good papers on
PubMed?
So stable, unique identifiers are way that
we can actually start to understand publications
free text without doing a whole lot of data
wrangling.
Usually curators and data wranglers turn text
and data into linked data objects by adding
these kind of identifiers, but anyone can
do this.
So for example, ORCID is a researcher ID.
If you do not have your ORCID, I would highly
recommend that you type ORCID into Google
and you try to find that.
Because ORCIDs are a way to disambiguate the
John Smiths, the Wangs of the world, and even
people like myself.
I certainly have an ORCID, and I put all my
papers into my ORCID record so that I understand
what is my intellectual output.
And I would encourage again everyone to do
the same.
Grant numbers are another type of number,
and I know that NIH has been asking for a
very long time about making sure that we get
the grant numbers, and we put those in properly,
and they go into PubMed, because then they
can ask very straightforward questions.
What has been produced out of this particular
funding mechanism?
What is the paper, what is the data that has
been produced?
So these are things to tag a particular paper.
DOI is a way, again, to tag a particular paper,
just like PubMed ID, those are both nice identifiers.
GeneIDs will tag things inside of papers.
SNIPIDs will tag things inside of papers.
And those kind of IDs actually disambiguate
what it is that the author is saying.
We have another type of ID called the RRID,
which tags the research resources, the antibodies,
cell lines, organism stocks, of a particular
paper.
Again, so that you can ask fairly simple questions.
Which gene were you really talking about?
Which snip is that?
Is it this particular codon, or is this codon?
We don't know that unless we actually put
in a snip ID.
For RRIDs, antibodies, we all know that antibodies
are really hard defined inside of papers.
But an identifier, RRID, when you look that
up, add it to your paper, it starts to become
like open data.
That paper starts to essentially add to the
total amount of knowledge about that particular
reagent, about that particular cell line.
And we know that this is one of the big pushes
to disambiguate some of the things that are
inside of papers and to make them more understandable.
So now we can talk a little bit about the
closed world versus open world.
These are assumptions that are being made
by databases.
A database assumes-- especially a relational
database assumes-- that the answer to your
question is inside of the database.
This is what's called the closed world assumption.
How much money do I have in the bank?
You have x amount of money in the bank.
That is the kind of question that a database
is really, really
good at answering.
Now if I want to know all genes related to
Parkinson's disease, that's a little bit of
a different question.
That's a biological question.
And it assumes that the answer would be most
likely not in a database.
Certainly not in one database.
Maybe not even in the totality of all of the
databases out there.
So the literature actually covers a small
part of all biological knowledge.
And traditional databases still, even with
the multitude of these databases, only cover
a small part of what's known in literature.
So when we ask databases big open world questions
which really are biological questions, we
might be running into some assumption problems.
Because we want to know as biologists the
open world things, but databases are very,
very good at telling us about the closed world,
about the world that's inside of the database.
So exploration and visualization.
It's not actually completely useful.
But let's see how close we can get to an open
world with some of the bigger databases with
some of the warehouses.
So when we start to look at data analysis,
and we start to explore it, what are the sorts
of things that you can do when we have a lot
of data together?
And this is one of the gap analyses that we
did with the Neuroscience Information Framework
data.
So each of these columns actually represents
a single database.
And some of them obviously have more data,
some of them have less data.
So that the darker the green, the more the
data.
And then here in this particular column, there's
a whole slew of labels.
And now each of these labels is related to
the brain.
And in fact, some of them are actually linked
to forebrain, some of them are midbrain, and
some of them are hindbrain structures.
So we understand that.
And there's the magnitude of the data.
So when we look across all data sources--
so this is around 100 and some odd different
data sources.
And we say, well, what do we know about any
structure in the forebrain, versus any structure
in the midbrain, and any structure in the
hindbrain?
Do we know more about forebrain or midbrain?
It turns out that if you then count up the
total number of data points that are essentially
known about the forebrain, it turns out to
be much, much larger than the data points
known about the midbrain.
And here's the thing, though.
When we look at connectivity matrices in the
brain, it turns out that the midbrain is actually
really highly connected.
So we should know more about it.
But when we look at the data, we don't know
as much about it as we do about forebrain
structures.
So because we have an ontology where we know
what we should know, and because we have a
lot of different databases all in one system,
we can actually know what is labeled, what
is a part of the data structure in each of
those particular databases.
Then we can actually start to do a gap analysis,
which is, where should we look?
Perhaps the midbrain would be a great place
to look, because there isn't as much data
covering midbrain
structures, and they're likely very important.
So we can do a lot of other fun things.
There is a concept of a homunculus in neuroscience,
and a homunculus is the representation of
the body on the brain.
So each animal has a representation of the
skin of the body, and we know that when we
actually redraw this representation of the
body, it's not exactly proportional to the
skin that actually covers it.
So we know that the lips, the tongue, the
hands, the fingers are very, very well represented
in the brain.
So they're drawn in a homunculus as very large.
Whereas you know the back and the stomach
are actually very small compared to the amount
of brain that actually covers understanding
and processing of the information from, say,
the lips.
So there is a homunculus in data.
So each of these points-- if we look at each
of these points on this particular graph--
is a disease term like Alzheimer's.
And there's lots and lots of disease terms,
because there is an ontology, so it's a very
long list of all sorts of disease terms.
And so what we've asked is let's look at all
of the terms across all of the databases.
And let's plot that versus Reporter.
Now, Reporter gives us an idea of what grants
have been funded, and they also cover disease
terms.
So it turns out, now I haven't done a full
correlation on this, but it looks pretty darn
good that if you fund it, data will come.
So it turns out that if there are grants that
are actually funded to look at a particular
disease, you tend to get more data points.
So the data points are here and the number
of grants funded are here.
So that kind of tells us that what we fund
is actually very, very important in terms
of what we see in the data space.
And I want to hit this one more time.
Comprehensive indices are usually the most
critical to biologists.
So one such comprehensive index is the antibody
registry.
This has about 2.5 million antibodies, which
is about as many antibodies as we can probably
get to.
There are certainly some things missing, but
it's something that's being worked on.
But you can ask certain questions, such as,
well, let's see what all the different genes
are, and this is running the 30,000 human
genes, this is down sampled, across any results
from the antibody registry.
So how many antibodies are there for most
genes?
Turns out for about half of the genes, we
actually have between 11 and 100 antibodies.
So there's pretty good coverage of this type
of reagent for anything you might want to
hit.
Some of the pseudogenes, and the predictive
genes have not been covered.
But most of the genome is very well covered
by lots and lots of reagents.
So fun things that we can know.
So databases really provide structured data,
and therefore they can tell us what data is
available.
Warehouses start to actually show places where
there is no data.
But what if we don't have a database to cover
the thing that want to know about?
What if there is only text?
Well, this is where we would get into natural
language processing
and a talk in about five weeks.
So natural language processing is a whole
field of computer science.
Deals with artificial intelligence, computational
linguistics.
It's very, very concerned with interactions
between computers and human languages.
So remember your second grade teacher, your
third grade teacher made you do these diagrams
of sentences.
Well, it turns out that computer scientists
have been able to train computers to do this.
So had I known that I could have cheated in
second grade, maybe I would have done it.
But now there are lots and lots of different
methods.
The Stanford parser and others are available
to researchers that would like to figure out
how to diagram sentences.
There are also a lot of statistical algorithms,
like LDA and others, that actually show which
part of a particular passage, which part of
a paragraph is more important than the other
parts.
So they pull out key words.
And so what I wanted to show you is just a
couple of examples on how this is being used
today inside of biological databases.
So one of the issues with functional magnetic
resonance imaging studies is that everyone
tries to tell us which parts of the brain
lit up, which parts use up more glucose, when
a particular task is being done.
So now there's a lot of people who do this
kind of work, and they all try to tag these
different parts in the brain.
But getting that information into a database
is actually relatively difficult and really
time consuming.
So Neurosynth, Talia Coney's database, has
actually utilized a lot of text mining in
order to make this process much faster and
simpler and create a complete dataset.
Not maybe as accurate as some of the human
curated, but certainly it's complete because
it houses all of the papers, and it basically
gets papers into the database very, very quickly.
So what it does is it removes a lot of the
talairach coordinates for the particular places
in the brain where the activation is actually
being reported.
Then it does a bunch of text mining and statistical
analysis to figure out which are the most
important terms in that particular text that
are being discussed.
So here is an example for working memory.
Now, working memory has about 901 studies
that have been reported on it.
And Tal's work essentially shows that this
particular term is most relevant to the particular
fMRI images, and then he replots this onto
a human brain, which is great.
So here are the activation foci for these
901 studies, and they actually do cluster.
So even though the data is coming from all
kinds of papers, and even though this is all
computer generated data, the computer is actually
pulling all of these 901 papers.
He didn't have to do this manually.
But what happens is, we can actually see a
pretty good clustering of what are the sorts
of things that are being reported about working
memory on the brain.
What are some of the other applications?
Well, there is a program called Textpresso,
and Textpresso's very cool.
There are lots of other tools that can actually
do this, there some that are commercial.
But this gives you an idea
of what are some of the other things that
text mining can do?
So when we have text, we can diagram sentences
we can figure out what's a noun we can figure
out what's a verb, et cetera.
But what we can also do is we can figure out
what are the terms inside of that particular
paper that are relevant to me?
And I can ask questions such as, give me all
sentences, Textpresso, that you know about
which list Parkinson's and a brain area.
Now, I'm asking for any brain area.
I'm not asking for the word, brain area.
If you typed this into Google, you will get
brain area Parkinson's.
But what you're really asking is, I want Parkinson's
disease, and tell me which brain areas are
most relevant to it.
So here's a sentence, one of the many hits
that Textpresso gave, and here is a match
for a sentence, Parkinson's, and talks about
the substantia nigra pars compacta.
Now, how do we know that the substantia nigra
pars compacta is a brain area?
Well, remember back I showed you that ontology?
Well the ontology says, substantia nigra pars
compacta is part of the brain.
So it is a brain area.
So what we can do is we can have large lists
of terms that are related to a particular
thing we want to know, like brain area, gene,
expression type, et cetera.
So there are large lookup lists which we can
actually feed into a text analysis system
to light up the kinds of things that we might
want to know about particular sentences.
And again, we're producing papers at a million
papers per year.
Something needs to help us sort through a
lot of this data.
And systems such as text mining systems are
actually starting to get pretty good, and
are able to show us some of the things that
we might not otherwise know.
So with that, what I wanted to do is I wanted
to thank you very much for listening, for
tuning in.
Thank you for the opportunity to talk to you
all, and I hope you tune in for the rest of
this series.
Thank you so much, Dr. Bandrowski.
We are out of time now, so we won't be able
to take questions.
But I think that's OK, because you were so
incredibly clear on this, and we all really
appreciate this talk.
So thank you very much.
And to everyone out there listening, thanks
for tuning in, and we will see you next week.
Bye bye.